hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to and I
have been attacked Pearl Harbor DIF you
will by a swarm brought on by the Angry
Video Game Nerd last week the Angry
Video Game Nerd posted this video
response I'm the fucking nerd and
there's this guy called a nostalgia
critic and he's been talking about me an
awful lot lately so here's my big
comeback to you and installed your
critic you suck
yes turd yeah I got pens and I'm not
afraid to use them you're mighty pens
don't scare me boy now you might be
thinking uh is that his comeback is that
all he's got of course your primitive
brain can't conjure up much more well no
I got more you're a poopy head Wow trust
those pens I really like how you
deciphered my hidden meaning
well you're close it was actually lick
my balls you piece of shit nostalgia
critic yes yes forgot to carry the one
I am the domination of the Internet you
diabolical creampuff not only have you
insulted my honor but you also left an
advertisement for my site at the end of
your video knowing damn well that so
many people would flood to my site that
they would overwhelm my video bandwidth
thus I would have to shut down the site
for a couple days
you are indeed a most worthy adversary
well put your money where your mouth is
nerd you think this job is easy you
think it's just a walk in the park to
review these horrible nostalgic movies
it's not and I'm gonna prove it to you I
challenge you Angry Video Game Nerd to
review the worst nostalgic movie that
you can find I'll even let you make the
choice or maybe one of your fans can
make a recommendation whatever you
choose you have to review this piece of
horror nostalgic shit on your show
what's the matter nerd - chicken -
yellow - take on the challenge ah
I eat pieces of yellow for breakfast and
chicken is my favorite color you know I
need I give you two days nerd two days
to respond to my challenge two days or
whenever is most convenient I'm the
Nostalgia Critic I remember it so you
don't have to to ordered too long
the angry video game nerd